doesn't give a [ __ ] on me follow his
handful
does your mommy like femmes in tall
platform shoes
[Music]
hi i'm megan and today i'm going to be
picking a date based on their pet
i'm looking for someone who knows who
they are and knows what they want
i dated someone with a dog and i dated
someone with a cat the dog requires
so much more work but i'm a dog person
but i like the independence of a cat but
i have no experience with cats so it's
really a toss up which direction
i'll go sometimes pets are the exact
same as their owners and sometimes
they're the
exact opposite so i'm gonna have to
figure out
which it is hey i'm jax and this is enzo
the cat you know whoever i date just
they need to get along with enzo enzo is
the sweetest cat
just so uh so personable loves people
loves to get scratches um very cuddly
just all around
10 out of 10 great animals so we're both
very outgoing
very extroverted very vocal i think
that she's gonna love enzo and i
definitely think she'll pick me on a
date
hi my name is deja and this is rhys she
came into my life about a year and a
half ago
i was living in indiana at the time with
my ex-girlfriend
and we decided to get two dachshunds i'm
a libra and she's in aries but my moon
is in aries it's almost like we have
this silent communication
and i love it i think the bachelorette
is going to love reese which is exactly
why i brought her because she's gonna
pick me
hi i'm janine and this is meatball i've
had her for
like four years i literally walked into
a shelter
and her paperwork said tv dog and i was
like oh this dog has a teeth it's a
famous dog
i can't adopt this dog so i asked one of
the people and they were like oh they
take the cutest dogs and put them on the
morning like a morning tv show and then
i had to do like a weird
silent bidding thing and i adopted her
we're both chill vibes i think
and physical touch is her love language
and my love language i'm coming into
this pretty confident uh because nobody
has ever met meatball and not been like
she's the greatest it's been a long year
and
i'm excited to meet some people and meet
some pets oh
hi oh you're beautiful
i don't know what to do with you but
you're pretty hello there my name is
enzo
i like scratches and backpacks this is
good to know
i'm here with my mom's roommate who i
love very much
give me a treat and i will love you
forever
and then she drew a smiley face are you
gonna
scratch me do you want to smell me like
a dog i don't know
okay taking your surroundings no
pressure
hey doesn't give a tummy this is cats
doesn't just it couldn't care less
you gotta you gotta work for love you
gotta you gotta work for it i understand
why people have cats i want to work for
enzo's love enzo's curious
i like that yeah he is obviously a
lesbian brought this cat in
not only because she's here to date me
but because she's a cat he has beautiful
eyes
maybe his owner's roommate has beautiful
eyes i do have beautiful eyes i could
see a long happy future with enzo were
he
to give me a chance the key to any cat's
heart you got to give him you gotta give
him treats you gotta give him time
much like an actual relationship
tiny licks enzo's just exploring enzo's
just living his freaking life
you know enzo's got a personality of his
own okay bye enzo
it was nice to meet you sorry you don't
like me very much maybe i'll meet your
mommy's roommate later and we can all
work on our relationship
[Music]
i've been crying i'm crying
i'm crying i'm gonna read this card okay
i love the pink aesthetics hi my name is
reese and when the universe made me she
really outdid herself
i love to travel and go on adventures
with mommy in fact we are going to
romania in three weeks
i am fiercely loyal to the people in my
life and very passionate about my toys
that a message was it a message
i don't know she has a little head on my
leg i would die for reese
i would die this is so cute actually she
is looking at me with these big
like puss in boots eyes you know from
shrek that's how she gets anything from
me
you're so beautiful if i were to get a
dog
i would steal this dog you're cute too
you can steal my dog i feel like someone
kind of
gentle but also like passionate would
have to have rhys
oh my god perceptive af it looks like
rhys
is looking at me in the face and going
you want to date my mom come on
you know you want to date her mom oh i
love you so much
this is already going to be a really
hard choice i mean it's just a perfect
match you guys kind of already have that
uh synchronicity going on with the pink
so it's a thing
hi reese i love you oh hi
hi you look familiar she has met
meatball before
oh hi i'm meatball i think i know
meatball
uh because my last roommate was friends
with her i'm
a feet tall on a good day
eight feet two two feet
and i require many pets i'm sorry i
didn't ask what to say before kissing
you but i just had to smiley face
i have such the opposite energy of what
meatball is giving off right now
people is a handful i wonder if your
mommy is also a freaking handful
i'm not a handful meatball's mom either
has to be the opposite and be
absolutely so chill she's sad that she
can't say hi to everyone
if meatballs mom is also this level of
energy
i'm far too depressed to run into a room
like that
i don't know how that would work because
i'm this level of energy so all three of
us together
that could be a great time or the worst
meatball comes in hot dude
i personally do not but that's kind of
our fun dynamic
okay it was nice to meet you i fear you
and i respect you okay i met three pets
today
but i only get to meet one person moment
of truth enzo
was everything i'm not looking for in a
person skittish
afraid wanted nothing to do with me but
i do like that a cat is independent
rhys the dog when i tell you i would
give my life for reese
and those sweet beautiful eyes though a
dog is a lot to take care of
and then there was meatball i want to be
friends with meatball
did we just get friend zoned right off
the top meatball and me have similar
energies
but do i want to spend an extended
period of time with that i can only make
one choice
at this point in my life i'm most
valuing
my independence and my ability to pick
up and go whenever i want and have no
reason to have to be home
i think a dog mom's priorities are gonna
be taking care of the dog which are good
i just don't want that to be my priority
at all and so pull through for me
so me and reese's mom can be friends
so you're rejecting my dog but i want to
go on a date with enzo's
mom's roommate okay i'm gonna be real
honest that was a twist
she picked me i'm excited to meet her
hello hi
i'm megan i'm jax nice to meet you nice
to meet you i'd shake your hand but i'm
not allowed
covet so this is your roommate's cat yes
yes i uh personally don't take care of
the cat but the cat spends a lot of time
in my room
so something you'd have to get used to
as long as i could spend a lot of time
in your room
too forward too far anyway
do you want to go on a date uh sure
we're on our way to get coffee
and i'm holding enzo yeah enzo's gotta
come along gotta come along for the
journey do you wanna
see me do you wanna see me again i'll
think about it fair enough
that's a yes i'm sure that's a yes well
i'd never had a cat join me on a date
before so that was an interesting
experience
but i really liked getting to know enzo
and jax
and i think i'll be seeing both of them
again very soon
[Music]
you